the precepts that goes on in the
classroom but everybody has like has to
stand up and say two things about
themselves so for you guys no one knew
who you were what you did
what would you stand up to say yeah I
don't know what would you say about
myself now it's New York why are your
hair extensions there's one you know I
would say my name Isabella you know
something that somebody wouldn't know
about me is that though I didn't wear
braces I used to have a huge gap between
my front teeth because I sucked my thumb
till I was in fifth grade that would be
one thing
I'm obsessed with like British mystery
shows release her the right place
yeah no I know I've been watching the
foils war during the break and I also
grew up like really loving like 70s funk
music you disco that's my mom was a DJ
okay so if I walked in the room I no one
knowing me I'd be like hi my name is
Jacob and I I like to snowboard number
one reason people should see this film
cuz it's really good at the end of the
day it's entertaining and fun and you
will laugh and you'll cry in the best
way because it reminds us and that and
we wanted we need to be reminded about
these days now more than ever you're the
toughest kid in that school
show them we can't blend in when you
were born to stand out
[Music]
[Music]
you
you